so today I will be presenting about
Python for dotnet or.net for pythons so
my name is Dana here I work as a senior
consultant at wood group in intelligent
operation group I'm also quite a net
core developer we have several of them
my handle nickname on online is dent
removal you can find me on Stack
Overflow github twitter linkedin
whichever channel he prefers so I I'm a
my background is mostly actually not
programming but I do have experience
with a Python C sharp mathematic VBA
MATLAB Pascal
back in the days
so also check out my some of my talks
about PI OMA
and excel wings so let me start with
some comparison plot about.net languages
and Python so this is the programming
community index this is like ranking of
programming languages and you can see
that Python and t-shirts are very
popular quite popular they're sent for
four or five in the ranking and but of
course I also looked at Stack Overflow
on Stack Overflow actually Python II is
getting a lot more popular this is
another index and here if we zoom in
c-sharp and python writing the same
region so very popular languages
now this is another index also about the
same popularity so what is the Python
for that net this is a package that
gives a nearly seamless integration with
a dotnet cor runtime and it's a powerful
scripting tool for that net developers
and so it works in both directions and
it runs on Windows Linux OSX and most
recently it also runs on windows
subsystem for Linux wsl Python 2.6 to
three point two point seven to three
point six so all major C Python versions
there is some work being done on running
it on pi PI and also dotnet core but
it's still a work in progress
so the history of the project is that it
was developed by Brian Lloyd heads-up
corporation in 2003 actually it was
developed before iron poison given
currently has three active developers so
that Victor he works at Intel banagic
keys he works at Starcraft and me so I
guess one disc label this talk does not
represent the views of my employer I
work at I use this library at work but I
will be talking about the open source
usage of this library there is a lot of
use of this library which is not visible
online it's closer
so this is a simple description of what
Python net is so there are two runtimes
we can see C Python and C a la runtime
and poison net is just a bridge it just
passes types and methods back and forth
so what is quite indeed good for so you
can reuse existing dotnet assemblies
dll's napi it's from Python without
writing wrapper code boilerplate code
you can write extensions for Python
internet also you can embed fight an
engine in dotnet app this is what I call
Dark Matter enterprise software where
there is a lot of c-sharp code out there
which it's not open source but they do
like to use one of this nice Python
libraries from Sify PI data stacks and
this is very easy way to integrate so we
use any Python libraries from that net
like I mentioned okay so this is some
statistics since 2016 the library was
downloaded over its reaching 100k
downloads $100,000 actually it's more if
we include all the other channels which
also later so this is how the project
looks on github we have over 700 stars
issues several hundred several hundred
pull requests so the project is tested
on Travis CI app where CI there is a
coverage for it we also tested on
Coverity for any detected
okay the license is MIT it used to be
soap and nobody know new words o P so we
had to switch to MIT with permission
from over 95% of contributors and where
we have a versioning scheme so semantic
versioning scheme runs on all major byte
inversions we also have a Stack Overflow
tag and there are almost so reaching
about 200 questions now on Stack
Overflow we also have two chat channels
slack and jitter so I will just mention
what is quite a net used right now so
this is a quantconnect is the open
source and C sharp F sharp algorithmic
trading platform of course you can find
more projects in the link I give so this
is a financial training algorithmic
trading platform and they recently added
Python support using Python net
so this is another example this is the
chemical process simulator which runs on
Windows Linux iOS Android and it uses
quite a net for using some optimization
libraries this is the actually quite
different use of Python it
this is abstraction over webview
components on all major platforms
it's called pi webview this is sort of
like electron but for python and this is
one of example applications built using
this pi webview ok this one is even
larger and this is toga this is the UI
widget toolkit it's also called pi PI D
D where it's a project by Russell McGee
if I pronounce his name correctly he is
a he is former director of Python a
Django Software Foundation and so for
Windows it uses Python net under the
hood but it's a cross-platform UI widget
toolkit that runs on even mobile
applications so this is another example
this is this is a library for loading
the deal well with other business so
32-bit to 64-bit and vice-versa
interrupt using Python net and this is
used by laboratories government
laboratories in New Zealand apparently
it's all open source this is all open
source usage I'm showing right now so
this is another one I found recently
this is they claim that this is a I
platform and they claim that they're
faster than tend to flow you can find it
online check it out they use Python net
so now of course bison net is used in a
lot of commercial applications for
example and one company is Oxford
Instruments used by banking investment
energy automation industries okay so I
have a quick question before I go into
details how many used
ironpython five win32 comm x python net
in the LG series okay
so probably a third of the auditory now
okay so installation and deployment
options we have packages that you can
install using tip VIP VIP install Python
net it installs wheels so it's a binary
package on windows on Linux we can do
that it builds using the installed
version of mono and other dependencies
the same on Mac OS it's not wheels now
we also have Condor packages this was
external contribution for dotnet users
there is a new gate packages so you can
do nougat and you can use nougat
compliment install package right Annette
and this is example and you can use it
from dotnet applications there are some
quirks with Annette so let's document it
in issue tracker also we provide docker
images so the other images is very nice
way because it everything is set up in
on Linux Mona environment you can do
both embedding and extending you don't
have to worry about installation all the
tendencies also win Python distribution
for Windows comes with Python net
included
so now another nice option is that you
can actually deploy easily applications
built with a Python net using a pine
solar or ch3 and most recently briefcase
from PI the project I mentioned so
briefcase makes MSI installers for your
Python apps that use tighten it so the
instructions are very simple pine solar
Python app with dotnet the py and price
both PI installer and T X 3s come with
built-in hooks for Python it oh and this
is a one one very complicated example of
standalone application built
it's a mana game engine app it's a set
console is a is a retro-style
game engine built by one of Microsoft
employees and it uses so there is one
example using poison net how to build a
simple snake game and it's packaged in
this issue tracker there is description
so with the Python net build there
actually comes a lot of nice utilities
and sample apps so one of them is an
Python executable it works
cross-platform and this is the console
app which is an example of C Python
embedded in dotnet and also this is a
Python interactive prompt so what this
does is it it actually embed the CLR
runtime and it looks like a regular
poisoning interpreter you can see I do
import system and system is dotnet
namespace you can see I put net output
the.net version this
so so there are also demo apps there is
wind forums apps which runs on dotnet
and more and I actually found recently
that it runs on Windows Linux web system
with a hex server and but WinForms is
the sort of legacy and right now the
desktop applications are the belt with
WPF on Windows and so we have also have
examples for this so WPF is very nice it
comes with visual designer and example
and you can use Visual Studio designer
and also you can even debug samo so this
is the example I mentioned so this is
Mona embedded in C Python running in
Linux subsystem on Windows with x11
server and you can see this is an
example app and so all I did is I just
went to this bash Windows shell import
CLR of course I had to install it
imported our import system you can see
it shows the platform as Unix
but it's actually running inside Windows
it's weird actually
how it runs and I just import one of the
demo apps and you can see the output
so I have here a demo maybe I will show
later if I have enough time actually let
me try it
so this is a actually an editor built
with the Python net but it's using
WinForms so you can type here and say if
this is just an example so that people
can just it out there is another app
here
so this is more more than this is WPS it
looks much nicer resolution is much
nicer and it has a much better rendering
so this is just for me to go back okay
so we also have very nice visual studio
ide experience the bills are using
msbuild
and it's actually driven by setup tools
in setup dot P Y so the builds are
necessary to pick the correct Python
runtime all the flags so it's all set by
this build so when you do PAP install
python net if it's from source it will
use that so intelligence there is also
intelligence but this requires switching
between environments currently so you
can do even in thousands on dotnet
assemblies but you have to switch to
ironpython testing so we have unit tests
extensive unit tests and these are both
for the c-sharp site and the Python site
and this can be run from visual studio
although recently we switch to PI test
and this part doesn't run is getting in
pivot Python tools for visual still
there is open issue for them so
debugging debugging is actually
debugging you can do mix mode cross
language debugging you can the remote
attach debugging cross-platform
debugging all this works fight Annette
so you can debug actually from C sharp
to poison and back and forth and you can
even debug if you want in touch the
Python runtime so I'll show some
examples later in the restaurant demos
in the end of presentation there is also
interactive c-sharp shell in Visual
Studio which is very nice for exploring
the Python runtime so but it's limited
to 32 bit so I'm using script es and I
see sharp for 64-bit support and
interpreters
so this is just a look of a solution
Explorer so you can see we have a few
projects here there are three projects
just related to testing platinum bearing
test Python test tests and you can see
there are there is a Python project
highlighted all the rest is C sharp so
python net is implemented in c sure but
it's using ship C Python C API under the
hood there is console app this is n
Python executable I mentioned before CLR
module is actually compiled to CLR that
PYD which you can do import CLR Python
runtime is the main code and that's
where the hooks are handled between
Python and dotnet so the I'll skip this
for now so if we have time later I will
show demo so disclaimer Python that
doesn't implement Python as first-class
healer language for that we have
ironpython so this is just an interrupt
another cool project is a pigeon
this is JIT compilation of c python
bytecode - IL bytecode and this is
completely compatible with c python
although the speed is not good yet it's
working progress
so getting started
so normally vital networks just as is
except dotnet specific bit in in that
case it's the way it should work in
c-sharp also for compatibility with
ironpython community we try to match the
syntax as much as possible with
ironpython
a good way to start this you just
explore the net usage interactively and
we'll do this in this tutorial so if you
get stuck there are a lot of unit tests
you can explore demos one problem we
have we don't have very good
documentation not much documentation I
should admit importing modules so this
is how importing work you just do import
CLR and then you can import CLR
namespaces just as regular Python
packages in this case I'm importing
system collections so types Romania
loaded assembly may be imported to load
and assembly use at reference so if you
need to use specific assemblies dotnet
assemblies you just add reference to
that assembly now if it's located in
custom directory it will be imported you
need to first append it to system path
oh so you can use dotnet classes struct
interfaces delegate so this is how you
create for example from system that
drawing import point so this is this is
just a regular Python syntax so now
there is a lot of issues with
overloading and for that we have worked
around so method overloading is very
complicated
especially when we are dealing with a
cross language code so in what cases a
person for that net can determine the
correct constructor if you're
initializing classes but in some cases
you may want to specify the specific
explicit constructor and for that we
have this overload at through attribute
so you can basically specify the types
you can see here char in 32 and this
will use a specific overload if the
arguments are somehow not explicit
implicit ambiguous so you can also use
genetic types so so here is an example
basically we're creating a hash table
dictionary and you can specify the types
a using indexing scheme of C Python so
this is using like a square brackets
indexing so
so you can also use Python pipes if
there is a matching dotnet pipe so now
you can also subclass dotnet dotnet
types in Python and add additional
capabilities in Python and you can see
example demo apps for how this is done
so now we can also use fields and
properties so fields and properties are
very common in c-sharp they are just
regular attributes now indexer is a very
interesting concept in future we also
have it very similar thing in Python so
for example here I am creating an
indexer support so for that I will have
to load something special and this is
called CLR magic so when you do p IP
install healer magic this actually loads
into Jupiter notebook and the kernel
magic that you can use seizure code but
net code directly from Python kernel
this is very similar to other cell
magics
like there is one for Julie for R and so
on and so we built one for dotnet why
not this was built partially by Savior
Duprey who is caught all this talk and
he is a Microsoft researcher in Paris I
just packaged it in the PGI takács so so
I'm creating here an indexer so this is
actually actual seizure code that's
running inside Jupiter notebook in a
Python kernel
and you can see I can basically what
indexer does is let me show you so what
it does is you could instantiate an
indexer you can assign ID x-15 equal to
ABC and then you can index it either by
ABC or five and if the index is not
available it puts an A this is very
thank you
this is sort of like order a dictionary
in Python so using methods this behave
as normal Poisson method method there is
some difference if you have static or
versus instance methods so this is just
example of using internet methods okay
now you can also do help on dotnet
objects you can see here I'm doing help
on environment and it generates this
pretty large document so you can export
this document so the way it works is in
it introspect the.net object for any
metadata that can be grabbed and put in
to help to overload it and genetic
matrix we already talked a little bit
about this so like I mentioned there is
overloads let's show some syntax here
so
so we can basically generate this kid
I'm making a generic method of type T
and now using it from Python so you can
see it correctly grabs the types I can
use generic method of int or of string
and it correctly outputs the types so
exception handling is also very
exceptional very good so you can raise
and catch manage exceptions just the
same you would import Python exceptions
so you see here I'm using a dotnet
exception and catch it from poison
delegate an event I'll skip this because
last time I gave this during Meetup
I saw some sleepy people using erase so
the type system array is the base type
for all arrays in dotnet you can use
this in Python just like regular arrays
so this is the syntax so I am creating
array of type int with elements 1 & 2
and I'm converting into list and this is
the output so list is a Python list so
all the Python C sequence protocols are
supported on dotnet erase you can see I
can get the items get even with negative
syntax get lengths iterate over elements
multi-dimensional arrays are also
supported so this is index so this is
very similar to vampires but it works on
c-sharp arrays as well so collections if
the dotnet collection implements
ienumerable then you can use standard
iterator
for in syntax with the Python or in this
case what you see is I'm creating all
assemblies loaded in today's current
abdomen this is the dotnet concept for
current runtime environment and it shows
all the assemblies that that are loaded
currently socom objects although this is
very legacy comm object there used still
used a lot for example Excel provides
good comm support and other authors
product and comm is very easy language
to interrupt between different languages
although in Windows 10 there is no
winner T and it's still in very active
development we'll see what happens but
for calm support there is very basic
support so you can do early bindings so
for early binding there is standard
Microsoft tools for late have late time
late binding dynamic late binding the we
still have to have some boilerplate code
because it uses very special handling
in.net for late binding on common object
so type conversions were work very
straightforward there are some gotchas
so strings all strings are unicode then
so if it finds compatible dotnet type it
converts from Python and back so some
types are not are not actually there is
no direct mapping for example in there
is no built-in Python type for in 32 and
in 64 actually integers integers are
mapped
like that but it's more complicated in
Poisson integers are they don't have
size limit now so system decimal is
example here given so that there is no
direct netting yet although there is one
branch where we have support for it
decimal types are still different
between Python and dotnet in.net the
precision is set in is not configurable
in Python it's configurable so another
big part difference is value types
verses reference types and boxing so
let's give some example here so you can
see this syntax will not work like item
0 dot X equal to 1 this will not work
the C sharp developers will expect this
to work but there is some special things
going on within c-sharp and this can be
reproduced in Python so the way this has
to be worked around is you have to first
define items 0 to something and then do
that X on it so so this is correct way
to do it so I'm doing item X equal item
0 go to item
okay so there is this is still problem
on c-sharp side sometimes you have to
take care of this in even in c-sharp
okay embedding so now let's go to the
other side so you can actually embed a
Python runtime in dotnet so there is a
support for major Python objects PI
object pile is buydig pineapple
so my sand executable is a good way to
explore how this is used but let's give
some examples so at a very high level
you reference Python runtime DLL in your
build environment then you can call
Python engine initialize and this
initializes the Python engine and you
can import modules now there is a
simplified syntax we have PI that import
name and this actually takes care of
complicated stuff as global interpreter
lock which also later a little bit so so
all your calls to Python should
ninety-nine percent of time be within PI
dot Gil blocks so this ensure ensures
that you hold the global interpreter
lock when you are calling some methods
in the Python runtime and anything you
do with Python runtime you should hold
the Gil so python is not three threaded
they see Brighton and although
ironpython does have support for so
there is no global interpreter lock in
either on Python but in person that in
suprising there is and so you have to be
very careful to when you dealing with
global interpreter lock that's why we
provide convenience functions on the
lower level
there is okay so yeah let's give this so
here I'm calling numpy using a dotnet so
you can use least dotnet list to call
vampire now here I am going simple
from.net so I can solve equations using
simple in.net
so actually what you have just seen is
fighting embedded in python using python
that we need to go deeper so this is
inset inception so this is small example
to demonstrate this so I have some tens
of flow example here so you can call
tensorflow
this is somebody from Intel who did this
okay this is now this is a demo of
mixed-mode cross language debugging so
it's also available in wiki
so basically when you attach you just
select the corresponding engines which
is native manage it and Python and then
you can step between Python and dotnet
code and it even shows up in the call
stack now this is ok looks like a ton
out of our anti texted her details I'll
open up for questions anybody has any
questions did you want to ask just let
me in take the mic I think let's start
with you uh so for the Python Gil
management is it only applicable to the
low-level API or does all the high level
like dynamics tablets also have to be
done under Gil or does it take care of
it by itself if it needs to
so the Gil has to be so the question was
if Gil handled on both that Gil have to
be handled on both high-level and
low-level manually yes is that the
question pretty much so just even
example simply who actually
because so the Gil right now the Gil is
not managed for the user in Python net
so all the calls have to be trapped with
Phi dot Gil although we're thinking
about enabling this optionally like with
the global flag maybe now the plus side
is that actually some people run in
multi-threaded environment so they want
explicit management of Gil so that's why
we have it like that right now so there
is support for multi-threaded running of
vital net so but it's not documented
there it's like there is issue tracker
and there are some pull requests people
use it basically in multi-threaded code
yes okay thank you very much everyone
so I think you can explain that great
thank you